Here's a question.
Why would people call an audio recording app "game-changing," "in a different league"...
...and "the best app of the year"?
Not best audio recording app.
The best app.
Maybe because it does a whole lot more than just record.
It can transcribe in real time, so you can see every word being said.
Even hard words like "Worcestershire sauce"...
...and fast words like...
"How much wood would a woodchuck chuck if a woodchuck could chuck wood?"
And kinda confusing words like...
"I ate eight plates of cake."
It can recognize sounds you record...
...like music, dogs, and didgeridoos.
You can search all that stuff instantly to find the exact part you're looking for.
And now you can edit your recordings the same way you edit words in a doc.
Just highlight a sentence, and boom!
You're an audio editor.
What sound does a frog make?
Ribbit, ribbit.
And you can share those clips easily...
...by making videos with the waveform and transcript baked in just like this.
Ready to share in all the places you like to share stuff.
And it does all of this, minus the sharing part, without an internet connection.
In case you missed it, without an internet connection,...
...which means it all stays on your phone.
And it's all controlled by you.
Not bad for a recording app.